viele auch wir hier bei klicks und
propagieren das elektroauto als die
einzige saubere alternative um den
klimawandel noch zu bremsen aber ist das
auch richtig ist der co2 rucksack bei
der produktion nicht so groß dass ein
verbrenner am ende nicht doch die umwelt
mehr schont oder was passiert beim
lithium abbau ist das nicht eine
riesensauerei
genau darum geht es heute eine neue
studie gibt es dazu blick zum science
fiction steak nicht faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen erst mal zur klarstellung
natürlich sind fahrzeuge mit einem
wasserstoff antrieb auch eine wirklich
alternative allerdings zurzeit noch sehr
teuer
und wenn jetzt toyota tatsächlich mit
dem festkörper agro im nächsten jahr
schon kommen sollte dann ist die
technologie nur noch sehr schwer
einzuholen wir haben ja gerade bei pixum
science fiction als einer der ersten
medien darüber berichtet wasserstoff ist
zudem sehr flüchtig und es geht einfach
eine menge verloren weil es selbst durch
stahlwände diffundiert also austritt
also das akku ist auf dem vormarsch aber
was ist mit den ganzen chemikalien eben
zum beispiel lithium das für die
batterieproduktion in großen mengen
gebraucht wird eine große anbauregion
ist das dreiländereck bolivien chile und
argentinien
dort wird aus salz sehen lithium
gewonnen und dafür wird eine menge
wasser bündnis ist allerdings verglichen
mit dem abbau von seltenen erden oder
metallen aus der platingruppe ist der
abbau von lithium deutlich weniger
umweltschädlich und moderner bergbau
kann mineralien ohne große umwelteffekte
abbauen so die studie der punkt ist sind
es große kontrollierte minen oder kleine
unkontrollierte unterhalb lithium schon
mal einen vorteil da es in großen mengen
benötigt wird wird es meistens auch in
großen minen abgebaut laut einem wert
aus einer studie von 2011 sind es
unvorstellbare zwei millionen liter
wasser pro tonne lithium doch dieser
wert ist von förderstelle zur
förderstelle unterschiedlich in der
chilenischen atacama-wüste dürfte er
aufgrund der hohen lithium konzentration
er bei 400.000 liter liegen kurz zur
technik es funktioniert genauso wie bei
der salzgewinnung das lithium haltige
salz wird mit wasser auf riesigen
flächen verteilt das wasser verdunste
das lithium cannes gewonnen werden
wichtiger punkt das wasser geht nicht
verloren sondern verdunstet trotzdem ist
es regional entscheidend denn dort kann
es zum beispiel bauern fehlen in einer
doku rechnet das zdf vor das täglich 21
millionen liter sole wasser aus dem
atacama salz abgebaut werden und auch
dieser wert spricht eher für einen
niedrigeren wasserverbrauch in diesem
fall von etwa 600.000 liter pro tonnen
lithium zudem wird immer mehr salzwasser
aus dem meer genutzt und das
wassermanagement wird verbessert aber
selbst bei diesem wert werden zb für
einen großen tesla mit zwölf kilogramm
lithium akku 7200 liter wasser
verbraucht das ist fast genauso viel wie
ein pkw mit verbrennungsmotor und einem
verbrauch von sieben litern benzin auf
100 tausend kilometern und die
umweltfolgen der erdölförderung sehen
neben der co2 produktion von rund 16
tonnen für diese 7000 liter verseuchten
küsten flüsse und ganze landstriche die
verschmutzt werden und zudem wird
lithium inzwischen zum größten teil in
australien aus gestein gefördert hier
gibt es diese effekte gar nicht das
heißt dass der wasserverbrauch pro tonne
sich im weltweiten schnitt noch mal um
rund 40 prozent reduziert der
marktanteil der australier ist von 2016
36,8 auf jetzt 43 5 prozent gestiegen
und auch in deutschland soll lithium
wieder zu einer renaissance des bergbaus
führen 125.000 tonnen werden im
erzgebirge vermutet werden sechs
milliarden euro wir werden uns in
zukunft auch weiter mit den folgen der
elektromobilität beschäftigen die
batterien der zukunft drauf klicken
anschauen und doktor watson abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran